avec nous sophie coislin l
épidémiologiste à l'institut national de
santé publique belge
bonjour merci d'être en direct avec
monture rt frontières comment jugez vous
cette décision de couvre-feu et de
fermeture des restaurants et des bars
alors je vais pas me prononcer sur la
justesse des mesures la seule chose que
je puis sur laquelle je puis insisté
aujourd'hui c'est sur le fait que la
situation épidémiologique en belgique
n'est pas bonne du tout et qu'elle
nécessitait la prise de mesure ça c'est
une certitude que nous observons dans
les chiffres depuis maintenant deux
semaines mais qui se confirme
certainement depuis une semaine oui on
le voit l'irlande a décidé de re confiné
j'ai bien compris vous ne pouvez pas
juger les mesures mais est-ce que selon
vous ce scénario est possible en
belgique mais je pense que ce scénario
est plausible dans l'ensemble des pays
de l'union européenne pour ne signer
pour ne parler que de l'union européenne
il y à une crise sanitaire majeure et à
partir du moment où le virus se répand
voilà il faut un moment donné prendre
des mesures pour l'empêcher de se
répandre parce qu'on en connaît la
dangerosité et quelle est la situation
sur place pour les professionnels de
santé comme vous et je parle notamment
des médecins généralistes alors c'est
clair que au delà du fait que toutes ces
mesures visent en fait en premier à
empêcher les personnes de tomber malade
et en particulier celles qui vont
développer des formes sévères de la
maladie
il y à aussi l'impact sur la capacité de
notre système de soins à absorber
l'ensemble de ses patients et de leur
offrir les meilleurs soins possibles et
donc aujourd'hui on reçoit de fait des
signes autant de la part des médecins
généralistes que du monde hospitalier
par rapport à leurs craintes deux amants
être un moment donné débordé par le
nombre de patients qui se présentent à
leur porte
et justement que faire pour limiter
leurs craintes
eh bien ce sont en partie donc ces
mesures qui ont pour but de diminuer la
pression
la circulation du virus au sein de la
population et
defacto diminuer le nombre de patients
chez donc ses médecins généralistes et
puis aussi dans le système hospitalier
pour les patients qui présenteront des
formes sévères prendre des mesures est
aujourd'hui indispensable
alors on parle beaucoup de langues oise
de la population des belges mais aussi
de tous les particuliers du monde entier
que faire justement pour diminuer le
stress et angoisse de ces gens-là
écouter de manière générale depuis le
début de l'épidémie il n'ya d'une part
pas de solution miracle
et c'est vrai que c'est ce stress on en
est bien tous conscients on le subit
d'ailleurs tous et si voilà un jour
quelqu'un a une solution miracle nous on
est très demandeur de savoir comment
faire en sorte pour diminuer ce stress
je pense que ce qui est surtout
important c'est que la population se
rende compte qu'elle est un acteur
essentiel de la lutte contre ce virus et
que si chaque personne applique les
mesures qui sont recommandées en termes
de distance sociale d'hygiène etc
on n'arrivera certainement à à contenir
l'extension de l'épidémie
mais pour ça on a besoin de l'ensemble
de la population c'est un message qu'on
essaye de faire passer qui n'est pas
toujours bien compris ou bien perçu
peut-être certainement qu'on doit encore
faire des efforts de communication en ce
sens
est ce que vous êtes optimiste pour la
suite il faut rester optimiste sinon on
arrête tout non bien sûr il faut
continuer à se dire que on va voir le
bout du tunnel mais que pour ça on a
vraiment besoin de l'adhésion de
l'ensemble des citoyens pour appliquer
les mesures les autorités pourront
prendre toutes les mesures qu'elle
souhaite
si chaque citoyen ne s'approprie pas ce
combat on n'y arrivera pas merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sophie coislin
je rappelle que vous êtes
épidémiologiste à l'institut national de
santé publique belge merci